do you think you take somebody to a
family event or something like that on a
first date
really see that's the kind of [ __ ] i do
that's why i'm laughing that's so cheap
what was your first date he took me his
family reunion
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
what first of all you're not a rapper
and your name is sticky finger
streets huh probably from touching
you're from touching your own butt
probably
dude i'm cracking into this chef pals
man now tell me about this man
that's uh that's ribs that's a link and
that's sauce
oh wow there's a lot of explanation i
got for that and is this sauce this is
that homemade hit
homemade hit this this is that you've
been thinking now listen
do not get the microphones all sticky
brandon yeah i tried it
huh it's my mic don't you call you're
right
there you go get in but here's the thing
you're gonna deep throat that dog for us
no i'm not what you've been talking
about that [ __ ] you've been talking all
that [ __ ] i can deep throw this dog
all right dude i don't care bro dude you
don't you're taking a foot long dodger
dog and just
definitely all right dog nah bruh you've
been awesome
you being wildly gay right now dude this
is barbecue got me feeling sweet
right you was feeling sweet when i met
you i put that little sugar in the tank
but you put some sweet barbecue sauce
around me dude dude you look like joey
best nuts dude
how many of these franks you gonna
swallow i bet huh
i can't believe you pulled it together
chef
he has pal yeah now and [ __ ] yeah this
is some legit [ __ ] man
now now there's when it comes to
barbecue i don't want to say i have my
master's degree in it but
dude you're dressed there bro you're
dressed like the top valet bro ever
yeah man just park it bro
[Laughter]
don't park it wherever i'll get it
[Laughter]
everybody has that friend that thinks
yeah just park it dog
park it across town i'll get it
everybody has that valet friend that
thinks they're like the best valet
oh damn look at that logo babe wow they
got your little gap and everything
yeah i'm proud of that they're really
coming together yeah
seeing it different now he seemed a
little bit more like a businessman dude
you know y'all bullied me into this [ __ ]
bully you in the business dog it's like
shark tank doug
he just went out of order he got chained
first and then he's starting to make
money
yeah usually it's the other way around
correct i mean
now tell us about the sauce man it's a
sweet hickory
taste to it what's the sauce called have
given names yet do you want us to do
that too i'd rather y'all do that
they all come up with great names how's
that how's that frank on them lips dog
the lips missed them frank i don't know
why do you
why do you keep bringing up gay things
why is
[Laughter]
you are man now i gotta now i got a gay
barbecue business
[Laughter]
i've seen this trick from every agent in
this town bro it's funny money's money
dog money's money money
gays are welcome like jordan said even
republicans buy shoes doug
yeah pick a side dude what i'm saying is
this man that's why i have the bun is
there so your lips don't have to touch
the meat bro
and my grandfather told me that i'm the
wise man
the wise wise man yeah that [ __ ] is
fantastic
for a camera i haven't eaten today
you're a goddamn barbecue angel man
yeah i'm trying now yeah well you got
some tips they need like what's up man
that bri that's some of the best uh ribs
i've had man again i'm really you're
kind of sore
yeah you name a barbecue joint your
boy's been to it on the road
that makes you kind of thick bro no
there's no doubt
hey don't trust a skinny chef that's
rule number one it's always like oh i'm
a carl's jr connoisseur
dude no you're an uber driver
but let's go connoisseur let's hear it
tell us what you know
give us the review it is basically boys
at truth barbecue shout out to truth
barbecue
houston houston doug oh i need to go
down there get like you know
go to like the i go on the motherland i
go in the back they got the smokers i
get the ins and outs of it doug
yeah you got to run a big production
here you get a smoking lacy food truck
you got me and theo slang and theo slang
in them
oh suddenly you're not slanging them now
immediately it's just me oh no no
you heard that though you got me and
theo's like yeah you're saying
just the bronze or whatever that is all
right i'm saying the ribs in the tri-tip
yeah that's more of a thing cat what
about you uh i will be bringing my feet
that's how you're saying that yes
dessert
i'm gonna pretend like i'm eating a rib
or a hot dog but never actually take a
bite
yeah yeah it's like a modified mannequin
that's the model of all your food new
rib coming out tuesday
yeah yeah holding it with their feet
yes holding it with their feet wow now
they should have i would love to see
home with a jalapeno rib or something
where they have ribs that are different
because usually ribs is just like a
basic kind of rib with the sauce
yeah the pork if you're saying you want
you want a little you want a little uh
kind of hors d'oeuvre on top of that you
want a little bit like a jalapeno like a
full blueberry on that [ __ ]
or yeah blueberry rib like if they did
bear ribs but there's blueberry sauce
well unless you guys aren't listening
that's what's going on you hear me
you guys do not listen man cause i'm
trying to say stuff and you just keep
telling me stuff
okay go you know ready set go okay i'm
like well what i'm saying is you're like
oh it's like
like a like a truck you're like no what
i'm telling you i'm trying to say
what i'm thinking is you're like oh man
you should go to a community college
it's like no no i don't think i'm taking
an advice from you no i didn't say that
i would never i would never encourage
you to go to community college i'm not
taking advice from you brain
mules okay i'm trying to just keep it
classy here man
what i was saying was it would be neat
if you did
ribs like they do wings and made them oh
we got this teriyaki stack right here we
got chef pel's
you know uh hidden garden you know wings
or whatever
hidden garden wings terrible idea
[Laughter]
hitting garden wings right yelled at us
just to listen to that
our idea is way better get a blueberry
spicy barbecue sauce
put some jalapenos on that full rack of
baby back ribs
look i hear you guys but what i'm asking
you is where's my ford fusion
okay that's what i want to know all i've
been waiting for
is my four ten minutes you said you got
me
yeah and you and your buddy who i don't
even know
are trying to sell me some type of meat
program
shout out to todd doral man wow this
this rib is very good though man
it really is man you made this yeah wow
well with help i've been learning a lot
sure
yeah i got to learn i got to start
somewhere you know i see a whole show he
tours
he gets he gets a food truck he goes
city city performs comedy
tries their local sauce finds his flavor
and it's off to the races bro who am i
going for we do live we do live kingdoms
things me and theo start touring
together
you got a [ __ ] food truck out front
just think of the numbers
oh wow thighs fiery that's your name
[Laughter]
starring thighs for harry boom and just
show those
taking the back flip town yeah this
needle got that
kick and then you just rattle off 70
backflips in a row
and each meat each sauce has a certain
number of backflips in it
yeah that's how much kick it has that's
how i adjust the spice
yeah with backflips i mean i really
think we got something here this will
make you do 15
backflips yeah this [ __ ] will make you
back yeah this [ __ ] will take you back
in time this is that uh marty mcfly
and i need a a second one because i know
chef pal is smoking
uh what it's called but anyways i love
away sauce
away sauce i know you need a second
flavor you can do that well you got to
have
multiple sauces you got you got your
your coffee i'm going to have multiple
sauces you have to
you need a mustard base sauce okay you
know you have the thicker sauce
more of a kansas city rub yeah you need
that drizzle that's south carolina
drizzle yup
you need that there's so much and
where's your favorite place
well there's a few but my all-time
favorites truth barbecue or brothers
barbecue in denver
brothers in denver truth barbecue in
houston there's a few men so that's the
motherland
truth barbecue's probably the motherland
yeah okay that's where i need to go
learn
you gotta if you want barbecue the best
barbecue's in texas people tell you
kansas city
and they're full of [ __ ] i have that
great barbecue in st louis though
how's it in louisiana something caught
me in there bro oh you good are you all
right
a little spicy something [ __ ] hit me
bro mystery
that mystery meat was just got sherlock
holmes in my freaking brain
huh you know what we got to work on
though chef is the oh i'll tell you guys
we have to work on science and
besides it's communication really
[Laughter]
yeah communication is key honest
yeah man this stuff is good so so how's
the actual recipe for the sauce coming
along i'm not you and anyone that you're
not telling anybody yet yeah you can
tell
when they let masterpiece come along and
take a [ __ ] bro
can't do that oh doggy god
oh we both feel so good thanks to
athletic greens man
yeah man you know one thing i will say
about it man you know there's some
things you take and they say it's good
for you
you know when you think i don't know is
it i don't know i think fake news
yeah but athletic greens oh real the
second
i imbibe it the second i get it in my
system i literally
feel just more taller more lucid more
capable
i literally feel better i feel more
handsome oh what drink could i go
is that brad pitt but i will say this it
makes you feel handsome in your diet it
makes you feel handsome
in that place where the lord wants you
to feel handsome that's in your heart
yep because it has it's it's a one
health drink that has 75 vitamins
minerals
and whole food sourced ingredients uh
it's got prebiotics probiotics
um it's got digestive enzymes adaptogens
superfoods
it's the one-stop shop to help your body
get all of its nutritional needs it's
all in one all you gotta do
it's in powder form you mix it with
water athletic greens requires less
capsules has superior absorption
doesn't include any binders or fillers
do just the good stuff
for your mouth it's that mike tyson of
healthy man it just
hits you with healthy you don't have to
wonder all day man oh my
for lunch do i need to have a salad do i
need to have three salads i need a bag
of spinach yeah what do i need to do
do i need to have a couple walnuts on
the way home you know it's all taken
care of
take the guesswork out of all of that
athleticgreens.com
k-a-t-s and claim our special offer
today
20 free travel packs valued at 79
with your first purchase that's athletic
greens.com
k-a-t-s man i'm wondering what i'm gonna
have to eat tonight i was thinking
let me guess hello fresh oh
boy you knew it daddy we be making the
same stuff
brother hello fresh is delicious
hellofresh offers so many recipes to
choose from each week to help you break
out your recipe rut
oh you know i quit ordering food all the
time to the crib man
no start making your own food it's
healthier it saves time
oh it's so nice dude hella fresh can
help you eat more sustainably
they have great freaking food man
dude it's flexible oh it's so flexible
dude flex on dude
bend me over a bridge bro and treat me
fresh
downward dog and put it in my mouth
that's what i'm saying
hello fresh is committed to making fresh
delicious food available now more than
ever
and they've taken extra steps to make
sure their employees and customers
are safe they are taking safety serious
uh and and the good thing about
hellofresh is if you want to do
something with your kiddo
you want to do something with your son
or your stepson or your mother your wife
or your ex-wife your aunt
but you don't know what to do oh you
know a lot of the you know the adventure
land is closed you know the water park
is closed the nature area
shut down you know family that cooks
together stays together yep
that's what she does invite him over say
hey let's cop let's cut up this cucumber
you know let's do this let's do that
good food fresh food it's good for you
they got it all
it brings people together and it's
highly encouraged
uh that it's america's number one meal
kit unbelievable and we have a deal for
you go to hellofresh.com
eight zero k a t s for eighty dollars
off including free shipping on your
first box
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com
slash 80 cat for more details
yup that's right hellofresh.com 80 cats
and the promo code is eight zero the
numbers
and then k-a-t-s all in a row i love
that you were in a uh baseball jersey
today's the first day of mlb son
hey man shut up major league baseball
coming back i wish they
incorporated a little ufc into major
league baseball like when you got to
second base you had to fight to third
interesting yeah a lot of good ideas
today man
thanks man great idea it's this sauce
man
it gives you yeah that's what it does it
gives you good ideas
it's like smart water you know they say
you drink smart water and then it's like
you drizzle
out bread bowls it gives you wings oh
red bull yeah if y'all don't want some
mints
you know nah i'm not we're good come on
bro oh yeah okay
i beat cove yeah dude you think i'm in
the bathroom at a nightclub all of a
sudden dude
[ __ ] tight enough dog he doesn't
really want the guy's chill outside
no he doesn't yeah what's that supposed
to be yeah what are you saying bro
you're out of your mind
i don't like mints with with my coffee i
don't like mints with
diet coke okay all right i could use a
toothpick though
i don't have that damn we need
toothpicks all right
i'm telling you shabbat the big thing we
need to work on sides besides like that
dude he just got a sauce in and now we
gotta
we gotta push them dude look at look at
look how far he's come this is fantastic
oh i agree man we got the logo you got
merch
bro bra tell you what you could do too
no no lie and i
posted two of them on my instagram wall
i ran to four rattlesnakes today did you
them [ __ ] oh i saw one hopping dude
this one was big if you blew bro one of
them wasn't that big one was small
and i said it was a baby the other one
was thick he's going across that that
first
nope that just that one that's a fatal
snake bruh yeah
doug that's that dirt serpent yep that's
that danger noodle that dude will steal
your freaking little cousin bro yep
that's that that's that poison what is
it earthworm jim that's a [ __ ]
rattlesnake a big ass rattlesnake hey
i'm not close to it dude that's wild
blue
that's that wide earth one yeah
that's how [ __ ] go missing right
there yeah she thought i was hitting on
her she
was getting on it i said yes she goes
what i go dude so
you don't see this giant rattlesnake you
shouldn't help i don't want to see her
get bit that's darwin bro
yeah you're right it's darwin when he's
stepping in god's way everybody's doing
all this stuff stepping in god's way
you're right god was like dude you're
[ __ ] the flow up dude yeah god's like
some rib addict is up here
i'm trying to collect some [ __ ] you
know i'm laying out a couple snakes you
know a couple of thought traps that's
fair and i'm [ __ ]
up this guy's like hey hey hey pull it
over missy i was trying to help that
little rattler right there
no it wasn't little and she goes oh
they're harmless all right
all right all right that's what she did
she went they're harmless
and she goes thank you though you can
hear the video she goes thank you
harmless marvelous have you seen
stephanie
stephanie harper disappeared
july mid-july right before baseball
season
that's cool you still rocking those
pants huh oh yeah i got these space
trousers on dude
you guys seen those trousers
look at them pants see colorful pants
make your ass pop
look at that covet cakes you got them
sad
the galaxies i got the moons and that
now it's that saturn
i'm not mad at them but man yeah what do
you think so what would you give this
the the meal experience brendan it was
fantastic it's unexpected too
um man the ribs solid yeah and they're
good i give it a nine and a half out of
ten
all right i'd say truth barbecue's a ten
yeah
look quit no truth barbecue and that
place could have gone out of business a
lot of things aren't even open
no no no sounds like i've never heard of
it
i'll take it we can't be eating the dogs
like that man
how else would you eat them i usually
eat him from the side if my dad was
alive if i'm eating with a senior man i
eat them from the side
because that's respectful you know yeah
one time at the rockies game i think i
don't know what they call the hot dogs
they're
basically their dodgers name dropping
also go on
they gave out free coupons for hot dogs
yeah and i was the thick kids everyone
gave me their coupons
i must ate 14 hot dogs wow and i threw
up everywhere
are you serious yeah we're in the
nosebleed section too go rockies that's
america dude
14 hot dogs that's living dude mm-hmm
i feel sick getting gassed up baby i
love it
oh dinger that's the rocky's mascot
danger he's probably the lamest mascot
in the league it was a purple dinosaur
really yeah you know you remember that
show dinosaurs went not the mama
it looks like that does it really did
you ever dine did you ever mascot
anywhere
uh no no that's our mascot that's why
the rockies suck
dinger oh friendly though that's a cute
little you are right though it does look
like the it's just weak
it looks like the mom no that's the baby
he doesn't look like him that baby was
cold-blooded baby was yeah but he was
whole [ __ ] dude yeah
well it's not a dad that's right not the
mom look how the baby
looked bro if i looked like that baby
i'd freaking be a straight d to
everybody
if i just come out of a penis and still
look like one dog
oh no i guess he looks more like i'd be
calling the cops his dad looks like [ __ ]
also
the sister the sister the sister that's
right dude that show was on
[ __ ] prime time abc dinosaurs
1991 there we go it only did two seasons
i think
maybe one oh i love that show
it only did two seasons mm-hmm oh i
thought it was a whole lucky they got
one you know what i'm saying it's on
eight prime time abc that was a good job
in dinosaurs
was it good though it was all like i
don't have to watch it remember the dad
would come in with the big uh
pale from work dude all it was was
stones dressed as dinosaurs
or roseanne there you go
because dan had a flannel and the
dinosaur dad had a flannel yeah you're
right
and they had like real problems like he
got like fired from his job they're all
stressed about money and they're great
and everybody has problems
it was weird i was like what is
happening the sister had to get an
abortion i'm like what the [ __ ]
these are dinosaurs dude it's socialism
it's a triceratops
the sister was all bougie and [ __ ] yeah
yeah she wanted like the new shoes and
stuff
the dad was good yeah they tried to be
like married with children but they
didn't have the pomp
they didn't have that yeah they didn't
have that al bundy yeah no one could
relate to them because they're
dinosaurs the dab was kind of soft
thick oh bundy was a gangster a bunny
was a straight savage
oh bundy couldn't make that shot al
bundy was a raging sexist
remember yeah i mean look he tried to do
his best dude he had two
dumb children oh god they were shook
and his wife peggy was no [ __ ] elon
musk either
oh i don't know but yeah that's a dumb
ass too i think he was a doctor he was a
nickel though and then all he would talk
about
is uh high school football at polk high
yeah
and he sold women's shoes hell yeah dude
was a legend
yeah a guy in the right bud i think he
died yeah did butt die
no he's not dead y'all think david man i
know him he's a nice guy what's he do
he has a show on uh
what is it called radio he does like a
he does like a radio show would you run
into about a retreat or something
um where'd i run into him no i think it
was like a ihop or something
that makes sense but i did his show one
time what is it called stitch
no will you look up his show real fast
there it is a test of courage
no david faustino i know him as bud
yeah i mean that was that famous
character and there were the bougie
neighbors i think it was christine and
the other bougie neighbor come over they
always had money the lesbians
yeah and then both of them had lesbian
haircut you remember did you watch any
of this cat growing up or no
nope i'm a little too young i'm too
young i am loving
marriage love and marriage
goes together like a horse in carriage
this i tell you brother
you can't have one without the mother
is that chin singing as well yeah this
is chin where is chad where's chin
oh you guys can't see him damn we got
him guys good to be with you guys again
i mean
i guess you see him so nice yeah kind of
why did we even bring him in i don't
know he'd come in and go all the way
back there
just being safe he writes the
description of the episode
[Laughter]
i have to be here i gotta let go of that
we need him dang chin you are
bandaged up huh just a tad bit
wow you look like that guy who died when
he was skiing downhill remember that guy
oh bono yeah
sonny bono bono from memphis
it wasn't from youtube he was sheriff's
husband yeah oh it was
oh gosh if i were shari's husband i'm
taking my own life as well
uh ed o'neal legit black belt the man is
very passionate about jiu jitsu al bundy
black belt from helio gracie who
rolled at the gracie really yeah wow he
announces like jiu jitsu tournaments and
[ __ ] yeah we had him i'm firing the kid
years years ago uh we had him firing the
kids
because heather gracie and him are
really close because he's like best
friends with their dad
wow yeah he was cool man at o'neill
and he was like a legit football player
too
legend dude how about he went from that
to modern
family there he is too yeah he was on
yeah from t.f.a.t.k to freaking modern
family
dude thinking about this he went married
with children fighting the kid
modern family just all hitters he's just
got the ark you know right
man look how young you guys are on there
dude
dang those are the fox days brian with
his og lids
yeah there's original hangers huh hey
hey was was that ed o'neal uh freddy
krueger
no no no not stupid
[Laughter]
only i think the only movie ed o'neill
did he did this movie called dutch
which yeah it was good yeah
is he not the freddy krueger guy no no
nope
do we know the freddy krueger guy we'll
find out i think it's charlton
um not dude nightmare on elm street
joshua has to scare me
when i was a kid like nightmare on elm
street scared you don't fall asleep son
went bro yeah dude we had real killers
in our neighborhood bro
that scared me dude this guy named
[ __ ] dwayne that would throw [ __ ]
through the window in the middle of the
night
and then kill you huh you'd throw it and
then kill it no but even if he doesn't
come in and kill you it's just as bad
because you're just laying in there it's
humid as [ __ ] now because all the
humidity is coming
outside alligators everywhere yeah you
just know that he's out there
then there's no yeah new orleans a real
problem that's
jason bro you said you said oh
his name is robert england england how
many people that's why we brought him
there we go chen comes in there you go
on his last episode on a very special
from downtown on a very special
wow chin makes it in
does that not look like [ __ ] at
o'neill a little bit dude
who cares your friend is dying in the
third room here
no he's fine i'm fine you talking about
the coveted ninja back there
why did we bring him bro hey
he's following it on i respect that man
thank you for coming in you're welcome
you know what man yeah i think we should
all kiss him at the end of this
dude no he's homo chin looks like he's
about to record a confessional for
gangland
and they [ __ ] with his voice
those guys always they always make it to
seem so much scarier than it really is
yeah you ever watch gangnam oh man oh
it's great
is it yeah yeah it was good yeah the
voice is always kind of it's like
you [ __ ] with this you died
you're like that doesn't even fit the
voice you know all right well
we're gonna shoot you down
damn what and it's like a little
guy in a in a wheelchair we can't even
talk yeah why don't they
well they just want to scare the [ __ ] in
why don't they do different voices why
they make them all sound so
dark and deep dude the worst is when
they get some kid in there and they're
like we're going to scare you boy
oh scared straight i'm not scared dude i
love scared straight why don't they do
it with gay kids
that's what i understand
i think they kind of do i think it might
that's scary straight though
i like when the the kid's hard oh
they're like you're gonna end up in
there he's like well i love it here
all right man and then move on to the
next did you see the part where the dude
make the
made the kid comb his chest hair no no
you've never seen that clip
oh bro he said comb my hair and it was
like
he was like a racist uh white kid and
his big black dude was like
punking him and then he's like take this
cone comb my chest hair and then the kid
was like
you never seen that clip oh rose they
scared the [ __ ] out of these kids though
man
working the salon right there dude
he made that kid comb his hair it's wild
and their their go-to is like i'll make
you my [ __ ] man you gonna be my girl
yeah
and then you say when he's like hold my
pocket yeah pull my pocket
oh damn yeah
yeah teenage girl was like she's telling
me yeah she swung out cause i can't even
do [ __ ] she's like
get in my face again she gets in and she
boom yeah
she's like no she goes you want to hit
me you want to hit me and the girl was
like
yeah that girl was gangster dang she got
well
and who'd you bet in that one nick
i i don't bet women's fight a lot unless
it's the over i'll take the over
two and a half rounds not a lot of
finishes yeah
speaking of fights can i tell a quick
story from la crosse wisconsin this week
yeah
[Laughter]
he was so excited about can we stop you
true
sounds like we're gonna get it no matter
what you know so brought my girlfriend
back and showed her downtown lacrosse
uh it's it's kind of quaint it's cute
but it's like got a big drinking scene
it was kind of dead
actually this weekend because of coveted
stuff but we saw this bride
uh on the screen here and she was just
shit-faced her
her groom was walking her she threw up
while she was smoking a sig
absolute truth i hate that yeah so then
we go to a bar and we start seeing
ambulances fly
uh past us and stuff and
they kept going we didn't hear what
happened and then i told my sister about
it when we saw her the next day
and then yesterday she sends me this
video she got hit by a car
she wishes she won
someone knocked it out on her wedding
day is that the groom uh no
uh no but the groom was wearing a
trump t-shirt and yelling white lives
matter and
it caused a fight uh and she was hitting
that dude with his
with her heel this is all like group
texts that are floating around lacrosse
with all the details
this is the most wisconsin thing i've
ever seen
for better or worse yeah and uh yeah it
was it was just wild was that pablo
escobar who hit her
who is that thick dude
run it back let me see the right hand
let me see that right hand was it a
punch was it you can see her drop in the
back of this video
oh is that her husband there yeah shirt
yeah oh and this guy's mad cause he said
white lives matter
this is before oh there she just dropped
oh sheesh
and then he rushes that dude and then
someone got shot this guy gets a
guillotine
right here looks like he knows what he's
doing a little bit
he's this on fight island
oh wow oh ddt'ed him dude ddt them in
white
jeans yeah and then yeah here's the
overhand dude ish
boom oh gosh
well a few lessons here thanks
[Laughter]
one probably don't get married nick all
excited
can i tell you something i thought it
was gonna be something nick's
yelling first of all yelling at us
didn't even notice that you're yelling
the whole time to show us a beating of a
woman
well she deserved it yeah yeah it
definitely seemed like she deserved
everything
she was hitting the guys well she i i'm
sorry i can't it's hard to see that good
play one more time she was hitting the
guy with her heel which is
no one should be no mansion not
oh you see that yeah you shouldn't knock
her out all right okay this wasn't as
fun as i thought sorry fellas
no look i'm just glad people are getting
out and about
yeah you know what i'm just happy no one
has mask on you know
[ __ ] dude yeah yeah that was uh that was
interesting though nick i'll give you
that
all right at least you guys did it man
oh so you guys but that you were
you walked by her filming her throwing
up and uh the cigarettes
yeah that was just a real gem yeah i
think you that when you saw her was
before or after 100
before because she had there's another
picture uh of
her eye was swollen shut completely and
she got taken to the hospital
they both they both got charged the guy
and the girl wow oh they both got to oh
they charged him
and there was and there was like it
escalated gunshots uh
oh hell yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah dude wow wow
wow
look yeah love my hometown across
wisconsin's lit
it's just lit man dude a great place to
vent some of this sauce chat
yeah if they would have had sauce they
wouldn't have done that that's true
they wouldn't have done that dude who
brings people together yeah if you're
licking your fingers man you can't be
beating each other you can't be fighting
you'd love each other finger looking
good yeah
and i love these little jars too chef i
mean this is a regular usually those
come with jam you know
yeah usually people put preserves in
those yam or
pickled something some pickled pickles
what else do you pickle pig's feet
pickle pigs feet we had a class when i
was young growing up it was like an
eating class where you learn how to eat
learn how to
eat like a at a dinner table and like a
with silverware everything you know like
etiquette
oh you'll be a proper human being
etiquette yeah where
you know how to you know pick up your
cup how are you doing set it down you
know
um and one of the things we ate was
pig's feet
and hogs had cheese too that's
disgusting yeah
it wasn't that bad the pixie weren't
that bad the hog said cheese i did not
like
just like old traditional southern foods
like old school like chitlins
yeah i don't know if you had chitlins or
not
but some type of gizzard i know we had
oh hey nicky more domestic violence
videos
[Laughter]
just so everybody doesn't think my
town's a complete [ __ ] hole here's
here's the good side of it
this is uh the view oops a lot of trees
this is the view from up on the bluff
main street mississippi river in the
back oh you can hear somebody shooting a
woman
that's why i don't have sound yeah good
call
looks nice man look i'm just glad to see
people are out and about man
and if you don't get if you and your
wife don't somebody doesn't get beaten
down in the street
on your wedding day are you really
living
you know don't remember that friend it's
obviously he took his wife to a
bw3s after a [ __ ] wedding too
shout out brothers
yeah dude and if you go to a place
called brothers you're going to get
probably hit by a black guy
oh this place called brothers yeah it's
like the college bar it's a chain in
a national championship take the tux off
and put a white lives matter shirt on
what was he thinking i don't know but
they seem like they're meant to be to be
honest that couple
yeah yeah man if you go looking for [ __ ]
you'll get [ __ ] you know yeah
with that guy in the white jeans was
ready to go yeah
and the punch was pretty solid man also
looked like he might have been a gay man
that she was hitting did that man seem
gay you think
he looked like yeah you look like is it
because of the white pants no he looks
like a sweet little pablo escobar
i think it's because i've only a lot of
times you'll see me gay men will hit
women maybe that's what it is in my head
you know what i'm saying kind of
yeah like a lot of times you see men and
women will get in a fight but it's
usually a woman and a gay man
there is some truth to that because i
feel like gay men are the only ones who
feel like it's okay to grope
women straight women yes and they get
away with it
it's like boat trip or fox news
employees yeah yeah
that's true dude dude you got to get
your ass touched if you're working at
the news
dude do you think i guess yeah maybe
women just get groped all the time
does that happen everywhere is it some
of it like do you notice that cat in
places where you like not obviously not
at tfatk but other places you've worked
at
uh where i've worked at no i do get
groped a lot when i go back home
by my like asian aunts i don't know what
it is older asian women will grope
the hell out of like younger girls i
don't know what it is they're like right
they're
no it's great one of those things where
it's like wow you hit puberty like your
tits are getting fat or like your ass
oh no touch that fat titty yeah oh damn
the two they go two hands there's the
one on two
uh really depends preference first of
all anybody puts
two hands on one tit is obviously blind
or it's a big titty oh that's true bro
but here's the thing asian girls usually
not that big yeah mid-range titties bro
low to mid-range kind of like the hill
in la crosse
yeah it's
did your girl like your hometown uh she
loved it uh she kind of saw the cd
underbelly after but uh
she saw the dark world she was she was
very charmed by it
yeah a lot we i also showed her my uh
campus of university of minnesota and
she loves europe and she was like a lot
of this like reminds me of europe
there's like stone arch bridges and [ __ ]
and
no homeless sam you need to take your
girl to europe now
keep your girls away from what's it
called
brothers no architecture oh because then
they want to go
on they all want to go to the park yeah
the pyramids do you mean africa yeah
yeah you're taking to vegas now they
want to go to freaking egypt you know
you go to bellagio they want to go to
italy you take them to ben and jerry's
now they want to go to iceland
[Laughter]
it never ends with a circus circus now
they won't go to london all of a sudden
wow dude for hymns is all about men's
wellness
need help with hair loss gotcha whoa
whoa can't get your wiener up we got you
you got a cold
huh i gotcha interested in mental health
or covet 19 home tests
yeah him's gotcha okay all right it's
tough going to the doctor man
it's real tough i know it takes forever
it's uncomfortable
check this out sixty-six seven men start
to lose their hair by age
35 dude every time i get an erection
some of my hair falls out
oh wow you got a lot of hair though
thanks to scientists can be
optional it's up to you you want to look
like george costanza you want to look
like fabio it's up to you
yeah remember when fabio hit that falcon
that time when he was on the roller
coaster
i think he was a pigeon yeah
that was a falcon dude probably doesn't
hit pigeons look right now we're saying
that hems has their best offer to date
if you're not happy
with your results after 90 days hymns
will give you a
full refund wow that's right ships
direct to your
door you have to be all self-conscious
about it today him has given you the
best offer yet
if you're not happy with it 90 days yep
hymns will give you your full refund
right now
you guys can try him for absolutely free
go to fourms.com
k-a-t-s that's for hims.com k-a-t-s and
look
you don't it's not you don't have to be
all secretive now you know it's like
when i was growing up if you wanted to
get erect you had to
meet a guy in an alley you know but now
four hymns will do it to you through the
mail man
also there's a full refund of price paid
available for first 90 days supply
refund requests must be made between 90
and 180 days after product shipment
delivered
prescription products require an online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine
if a prescriptions appropriate
restriction supply c website for full
details and important safety information
shin are you alive give us a life
update i'm still here wow i'm still
kicking
and how has it been yeah nobody even
none of us even care we're we're in here
eating
dude life goes on we're in here eating
watching the fights
frickin we don't even care that chin has
literally been
fighting death i feel great man
i just uh want to be very very careful
that's why i'm waiting this long it's
been
so many days i know that's what remember
i'm the only one in here that was
wearing masks like crazy
i'm just super super careful yeah the
irony
do you think you have it chan no not
anymore
it's been too many days yeah symptoms
went away a long time ago
it's been shin's head for three months
just got to be very careful that's it
damn dude it sounds like you're kind of
milking the system a little bit chin are
you
are you unemployment yeah you would know
yeah are you collecting unemployment no
no unemployment
oh wow and i'll still i'll be zooming in
or whatever i got to do keep working
damn that's amazing bruh i'm here three
three doors down
yeah we keep a good band yeah uh okay
just kidding
oh that's where you draw the line
three doors you know they got one song
kryptonite
i don't like that song which one do you
like it's a slower one it's called away
from the sun
oh yeah that is a good one yeah
kryptonite was bad from
[Music]
super kryptonite oh superman yeah
i remember running through the wet grass
getting my socks all wet remember that
song nope
desperately all right
guns and roses blazing new stein
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
she tattooed her eyeballs oh yeah no she
did yeah she did yeah that's not it
brother that's a new thing chef
that's what you've never seen dude naked
i'm sorry scared
beyond scared straight you've never seen
these inmates with their eyeballs
painted
they tattoo their eyeballs yeah red blue
green black is this true apparently
yellow black in him like that
i don't know right black ones
uncomfortable
man don't do that kind of [ __ ] here now
a lot of kids they don't want to pay to
have a
yeah a lot of them go blind so that's
what happens when you go yeah a lot of
them go blind
that's not real and this let me just say
first of all this is also a white sport
it seems like
mainly a white sport or asian oh no
that's definitely white
this is why it came from the inmates
though the inmates were the first
you remember the first guy kind of the
rosa park divide
stuff was like you know what i'll do it
i'll be the first guy
you know what that's a good point
inmates really start a lot of kind of
trends like that you know sagging your
pants yeah
they should have done it that meant you
were down for booty play oh really
that's where sagging came from damn they
should have done it in the civil war
because they said don't shoot until you
see the whites of their eyes so if you
tattoo your eye you can't shoot yeah
that's true that's an ugly thing it is
ugly
it's sad too when you do that to
yourself i think not this girl i'm
saying but
for this kind of for a reason it's kind
of hot let's watch the last video
channel probably ever see
i appreciate it let's get into the
episode huh yeah this is a new segment
called shoot your shot and it's
self-explanatory
she convinced that to our
marissa eyes i am from phoenix arizona
uh first and foremost i just want to say
that i absolutely adore you guys and
love the content that you produce every
week
um this is hands down my favorite
podcast and i look forward to listening
to it
every friday morning as soon as i get to
work um i was actually introduced to
your podcast from this guy
that i have really been into for quite
some time now uh his name is paul he's
absolutely amazing
and damn near perfect to me so i thought
what better way to
try to shoot my shot than to hopefully
get his attention here on the podcast
hopefully it works and hopefully my
friends here on king and the sting will
co-sign for me
but paul if you're listening
now was that a filter because her teeth
were blue too am i going [ __ ] crazy
i believe she's got an xc in this
barbecue sauce
were her teeth blue there's a little
ecstasy in that yeah a little bit in
there you know
her teeth were blue right yes no and her
hair's blue
no it isn't brendan it's like a tinge i
think she's got a filter on okay i think
it's a fun okay
yeah so she's down to prison okay so
she's looking for paul man i like it
and we gotta get uh paul if you're out
there send us your response
either way oh well it's like it's like
come get it dog and she's she's prepared
either way
if he's not into it she she knew that's
the chance she's taken
dang okay there you go just like that
wife out there
you hit somebody with a high heel [ __ ]
happens that's the chance you take it
man
i'm sure i'm sure if polly don't want
the cracker she's going to get a bunch
of other
dudes in them dms she might she might
not uh
but she is yes she thinks yeah yeah yeah
that's 20 bucks
look at her yeah beautiful girl yeah and
she can uh
i'll have to find out if she's cool with
us giving out her instagram in case paul
says no
oh i think she is i think she's
definitely attractive i just mean she
do we have enough creepy guys out there
that would be just senator dms i guess
we do i'm going to go ahead and say yes
there you go survey says
yes checking my dms yes
[Laughter]
oh here's somebody right here who's
obviously uh there's someone with the
same nose as theo
save some auction for the rest of us
fellas
dude i just inhale yeah all you guys
just paint
dies again went to the same doctor oh
gosh hey what's up brandon theo in the
gang
i got a quick uh king interstinger for
you black lives matter i'm out here in
amish country ohio
this is where i'm from uh you see the
people on the buggies you'll see them on
bikes i even saw a guy pushing a razor
scooter to get to work
so the king of sting it is the amish
lifestyle would you live it
no electricity uh no cars a simple life
let me know what you think gang gang
buzz buzz
buzz buzz man gang dang i'm a slideshow
that's out near lancaster out there i
think in p.a do you said he's in pa
where he is
um i don't know what do you think about
the almost lifestyle chappelle what do
you think
i like a simple life i don't need much i
don't even have a car
yeah you know gold you know if you're if
you're in the amish lifestyle you're
having a gold chain
yeah right now i can't have a gold chain
no you can't wear just little cortez
nikes either
okay no doug can't wear any of that
stuff
you ever seen a fly [ __ ] amish person
you've seen an amish person somehow i
mean i've seen i've seen kingpin you
ever seen that movie great
you know oh someone so overrated or
underrated i don't know which one means
underrated bill murray and that's so
funny
oh is his players all [ __ ] up
uh oh cat you could do it huh um
i feel like i could probably do it just
because my
i imagine that's how my parents lived in
vietnam but
i don't think i could do it now yeah
yeah it's crazy how like your parents
will be will live one life and then the
kids will live
and just how different it is you know
and how i i refuse to go camping
yeah yeah yeah it's like being almost
just like being just briefly amish
don't they send their kids out when they
turn 18 to like springer
yeah it's on the screen that's where it
goes from springer
so you get a chance to stunt and live a
lifestyle for a little while come back
do you have to come back no uh no it's
like up to you it's like
a trial period and they build all their
own [ __ ] too right
yeah they turn their own butter they
probably have no idea what's going on
right now
a lot of people in like my area they buy
their furniture from amish people
because it's all handcrafted and stuff
like they probably have no idea about
cobin that's a good question
like why are they everybody in [ __ ]
mass these days yeah are the amish
getting covered can you look that up
that's me a tough sell how long are
their kids allowed to leave for
like when they turn 18. ooh lancaster
county
that's where they're at pandemic taking
toll on amish
oh look at that little well damn look at
that little freaking nest chin
your chin is in that little thing if we
can zoom in on there we'll see him
sick
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh wow okay
what it hit the amish dude it did well
what did that say we didn't even see it
right it spread amongst the amish
yeah we didn't read it yeah dude read
the [ __ ] top line
son yeah that's just the bait
my trend upward will increase about 135
percent
statewide now it doesn't matter
i guess so how'd they get it if they
don't talk to anyone
they don't never see them driving over
there yeah i don't know man i said this
they didn't
nursing home infections were the driving
numbers there ah [ __ ] get out of here
it's nursing homes that's not amish yeah
a lot of the amsterdam we don't even
know then it says we don't know because
a lot of the amateurs are not being
tested they're choosing not to be tested
yet because they don't have it don't
[ __ ] with us
damn good for them like we don't have
your [ __ ] disease do they do they let
outsiders come in there
in their in their town i don't know a
lot about amish yeah
we should get an amish person on right
they wouldn't do it
you don't think no dude but somebody
that went to rum springer and then gay
came out and they came out you talked
someone who's changed who grew up in
that lifestyle
yeah oh maybe that guy who sent in the
video
oh yeah you know what to his nose yeah
i wish i had that little nose he has
i got this intake man
good day sir good day mate how you going
that's australian that's australian man
you got to spin around the globe do you
got to tap in your roots but we're
we're doing an all britain episode and
you're part british right half my mama
born and raised england stroud shout out
to stroud
really wow we're doing a full
episode of king of the sting dedicated
to the english
yup we're doing a full episode cats
dedicated to english because things are
getting rocky here in america
we might be coming back yeah we might be
coming back to the motherland
yeah so send in all your video
submissions
all england and inspired yep england
england inspired uk scotland and ireland
um
and other places that are also england
that we don't know yeah
welsh i think it's the welsh the well
that'd be uk yeah
yeah who's uh yeah the welsh and england
has better candy
also another good idea for king the
sting oh that's true maybe some british
candies if you have one that might be a
good yes
that might be a good king interesting
also they call chips crisp over there
them crisps so yeah we got ireland
northern ireland scotland
england and wales them the
i think they're the whales i've loved
you i always have oh
i'm not a poof dog i'm not a poof dog
so um healing get on it submit the video
england get on it submit the videos it's
gonna be for next week so get on it now
what else you got today
okay
hey theo hey brandon um this is like my
80s trying to make this video because
i'm so nervous
and i'm really sorry for the shaky
camera work but i am from the west coast
canada and i have a king and her singer
for you
um eating a lot on the first date should
you just be play and have the salad or
is it okay cola with the burger
fries milkshake all that um i personally
am a burgers girl but yeah i can't
understand
it eating a lot on the first date buzz
buzz
hey first of all she was talking very
fast like she's being held
i do want to say that she didn't have a
lot of time and look yeah
uh yeah uh kidnapping people in uh
forcing for somebody burgers or fries
in western canada
1114 harper avenue
this is me shooting my shot shooting my
shot for the police
i'm sorry we're just joking young lady
you seem like a beautiful young lady
yeah she's very attractive yeah well
brendan
there's a lot more to her than that dude
she obviously wants to know
she she's like being held hostage like
britney spears people think
britney spears has been trying to signal
her fans through her instagram videos
her dad has all her rights yeah like
power of attorney or something she can't
make any decisions and some fans will be
like we're yellow
and then the next video should be in all
yellow then like show a picture with
pigeons if you're
you know if you're in trouble and just
show pictures with a bunch of pigeons
like she's literally listening
hey y'all her freaking videos are
freaking absolutely ridiculous
it's so crazy okay dude it's very random
you seen the other stuff supposed to
compare to this like there's something
going on there
dude what do we know about women we
don't know [ __ ] yeah that's fair yeah
but you might be right though man you
might be right i'm sorry dude there's
like that's in this head
into it see i can't put my head in that
but what did this this girl want to know
eating on the first date do you just
have a little side salad you go for that
[ __ ] balls deep
i have the side salad you know side
salad
yeah i i like something that i can knife
and fork
oh really i show them that i'm fancy oh
show them your handy
you don't first date no no chicken wings
ribs
oh you did done well in that class i was
in then yeah i took that glance
you did yeah you can't you can't do
messy
stuff probably no spaghetti no pastas no
crawfish
no crumbs yeah no crawfish for me no
broccoli i don't know in louisiana you
could take a girl to a crawfish boil as
like a first date maybe
i think it's messy though dude
yeah that's true still sexual though too
it is a little bit that full rack of rib
you start
showing her you suck that rib bruh or
you get your plate you put crawfish and
her plate is just like
seven things of corn and she's like what
do i have all these
what i've just long corn
and she's sucking on the head yeah yeah
the second on the head yeah i think
there's a lot
bite the tail suck the head maybe it's
the second date you go for crawfish
yeah i know what's a good date where
it's a good date
spot man for dinner well chin's place
that he always goes exactly the best
korean barbecue's not bad it's pretty
damn good you cook for him too
yeah so it's sweet yeah yeah yeah it's
kind of annoying
[Laughter]
take it easy it's not the 50s bring your
own meat in there sometime i like to do
that for korean barbecue i'll sneak a
cut to my own meat
you know i'll toss some [ __ ] grapes
on that [ __ ] grill i'll sneak a
little bit of half of a swan neck or
something
myself somebody exotic i put some
[ __ ] ostrich on that [ __ ]
do a turkey neck or half a stretch
penguin [ __ ]
boom yeah it is nice when you bring some
of your own [ __ ] and people look over
and you gotta damn yeah
you gotta have a zebra rib hoe oh big
old rib on there
yeah yeah dude you got a [ __ ] yeah
you got a little bit of a leopard hip
over there
like get that elephant trunk on the
grill bro you're eating that endangered
species
now chin have you taken some first dates
to this type of place where you got this
disease at
[Laughter]
got the disease out yeah
what whatever let's this is a two-parter
first of all
yeah go for it where do you think you
got the disease at that you have
what do i think let's see let's
backtrack okay
i'm guessing when i don't know if i had
to put money on this i would say
possibly through brendan o'brien whoa
whoa whoa guy
what are you talking about what where's
your proof
there's no proof there's no way playing
gravity there's really no way to travel
with [ __ ] korean barbecue every other
goddamn day that's true you're out in a
lake that thousands of other people have
been in this year
a boat yeah that's true but i was with
my girlfriend she's pretty clean
does she have it no she's good she's
healthy how does she not have it then
she might be asymptomatic the last time
i saw was a weekend before
and then the monday that i worked i
didn't see her after that so
and have you heard from her or seen her
at all is she all right talk to her
everyday oh okay
good face down here she's good she's
great but what was your question has
been thinking
has he taken girls on dates at korean
bbq that's all he does that's his move
no and also the best i think the best
one is sushi
ooh sushi a little here's
here's the thing if you if you want some
problems and it happens with sushi you
eat sushi that went bad
that dates game set match true if you go
to a bad place
oh you're blowing up the toilet son but
who's eating bad who's he it happens at
the best of best places no
sometimes it's just a little tuna that's
been out a little too long
no it does and i think you know that as
a human species if you're supposed to be
alive and you
want and god wants you to be alive for a
long time then you
don't eat bad food that's going to kill
you because you know in your own brain
what's going on sometimes too late you
swallow that eel roll
there's a little funky sauce on there
that seems that you know your stomach's
going hey dog
date's over damn that's why you got to
stick with chef pal's sauce man
bring your own sauce no but cream
barbecue might be the best idea for a
first date
korean barbecue feed each other too what
do you think cat let's say you get a
female perspective they pump the break
just say chin over
culture bro don't deny him his culture
man i don't think so
he will kill himself in a puddle for his
wife
what have you seen those videos where
they die and then he's like walking
across my back
to get your shoes wet no yeah were you
saying cat they do that [ __ ] dude if he
was a girl his dad would have killed him
wait what i have no idea what's going on
you know what i'm talking about jen no
yeah you do all right well you're saying
oh cat what's your good first date
um korean barbecue i also like it if a
guy can cook if he cooks for me on the
first date i'm very impressed
hold on you got to go to the crib and he
cooks for you that's yes
that's a little that's a little mud like
yeah if you're like hey
let's say somebody was asking for a date
you're like oh where are we going he's
like my crib it's like jesus
and what if you what if he he goes to
the bathroom or something then he comes
out and catches you looking through his
stuff
why am i looking through his stuff why
wouldn't you yeah
why wouldn't you yeah i feel like girls
are smarter where if we wanted to snoop
we would snoop through your bathroom
yeah because then you can't just come in
you're not just walking into the
bathroom
lock the door but if you're in there for
too long i'd be like oh she took a [ __ ]
in my
bathroom which is fine that's that's a
human thing yeah people [ __ ] all the
time
everything's [ __ ] fun have you been to a
pet store before everything in there
shits
yeah yeah that's fair uh besides just
cooking at home where else cat
i i like italian food okay it gets messy
though
but the light you get a big sloppy
lasagna dude
she's not taking him to [ __ ] sbarros
dude
it's like a decent place he ain't drunk
[Laughter]
cardboard covered in lettuce that [ __ ]
is terrible dude
whatever man you guys don't know
anything tomorrow's is [ __ ] you gotta
get out more dude it's regional it's
nice it's
the i mean people like it what about uh
so yeah i think if you
have a place you could grill something
do you think you take somebody to a
family event or something like that on a
friday
really see that's the kind of [ __ ] i do
that's why i'm laughing that's so cheap
what was your first date he took me his
family
bro i'm not joking i just now remember
there was this really sweet girl
from saddle louisiana she came to my
brother's house for
dinner one time uh and she it was my
family dude and i hadn't even seen half
my family in like a year yeah so you
putting cats up
she's all over in the corner and my
brother and then we just moved in this
house and they had a real small table
so we all had to eat like really close
to each other
and it was the food was not good it was
so old
and my brother's kids were lit like just
newborn
just chaos chaos throwing [ __ ]
and it was just like who was this girl
i don't know yeah like i just met her
yeah well well no
i said i don't know but i'll you know
i'm trying to see how she handles the
pressure yeah let's put her right
that's funny let's put her right into
that deep oven where chin is right now
that's why i knew when he asked that
that's some deal [ __ ]
it makes me feel bad too why i do that
kind of stuff you know oh yeah
come to look my buddy mom passed away
one of my best friends has a funeral
today why don't we go to that tonight
pretty dope awake let's go do it you
know wear some wake
sexy you know dress kind of death sexy
let's do it man what else you got nick
we'll close out with the uh
uh highly friendly who's out did we even
start the show
i didn't even help that girl she wanted
to know if she didn't have a sandwich
no no you need
[Laughter]
do not let that captor say oh this is a
first date still
yeah yeah we're just 11 months into a
first date
it's a real long first date we're trying
to figure each other out
uh korean barbecue is the best idea
there you go korean barbecue
yeah campfire i think is a little too
scary
it's also annoying though if you go on a
date with a girl and she orders just
like a side salad
hey come on man then i got then i can't
get down
i can't order a full meal and i look
like an [ __ ] mm-hmm
oh yeah that's true let me get some
salad
yeah well then i gotta get a salad then
we're both starving
no no no you get two salads and she gets
you know or she gets two
salads like say you get a burger she
gets two salads
or you get two salads you know somebody
gets two salads you know all right
crazy you know
we gotta debate we'll close out with
this debate club well when's this sauce
coming out though i do want to know is
are we going to see a sauce at some
point are we still kind of perfecting
the recipe yeah perfecting you know just
working out the kings i mean i can't
wait to dive back into another set
yeah are you going to eat more after
this
thank you get a little taste of that
sauce again i just want you to
know what's going on there yeah no
finger licking you take that home
oh yeah i mean you put his whole finger
in it so he might as well yeah yeah
that's why i said that
little mason jar i'm trying to think of
what's in there man i'm tasting some
different elements
something hit me yeah did you guys ever
figure out what a tri-tip is
what did you say oh the cut yeah the
triceratops i think
oh yeah what yeah what part is that i
think tricera tried
the tri-tips uh of the hein right the
bet the very back find
what do you freaking pervert
go to cuts a barbecue hey let me see
that hind boy
yeah and everything's got to be cut a
certain way like you got to go uh
against the grain
yeah i like i like when they chop the
tri-tip up and you get the burnt heads
oh yes they're good oh yeah
they should have a picture of a cow and
then it shows it
just try tip what does it say beef cut
steaks
sirloins oh this is rib beef mince
brisket if you go cuts of beef it's
going to show a picture of a cow then we
can figure it out
or what is tri-tip you'll see
it's see there there there's the pick
i'm looking for
what is tri-tip
oh and there you go i see what you're
saying yeah okay and there we go
what i like is that london broil man
shout out i'll tell you the [ __ ] is
that flank steak you don't want that
no that prime rib hit her right there in
the middle of his back
let's go back to that pit can we nick
the pink one right
yeah so tinker i don't know let's go
back to that other one if we can
go into more detail i like that nice
that neck you like that lane what's up
with that what's up with that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
damn i don't [ __ ] with tongue either man
you don't
i got to draw the line somewhere i need
no tongue bro you eat the tongue i've
had
like language tacos nope oh yeah no what
are they
like cow tongue
tacos like tacos that leg have you had
it
yeah i will eat every part of the animal
damn
you eat the eyeball cat that's sexy bro
sometimes
if it's like on fish and stuff
you gotta pop that dude i think i [ __ ]
up that was his thick ass tongue they
cut into pieces
yep it doesn't go to waste though that's
good that's slurper and the best is if
he doesn't slurp her
that's gross bro if he just had
something real tasty then you get double
the taste
yeah that grilled slurper if you know if
they if the if the cow say if he just
had a snow cone or something all right
you get a little sweeter yeah so you get
that you know you're suddenly your
your tongue steak tastes like a little
bit of an ass is this the tongue
there's a picture of the tongue right
there yeah
nick can you pull up a geoduck and show
them what it looks like a geoduck yes
it's like a c yeah there you go another
version of like a clam
oh and don't you don't you stroke them
and then they spit so they're what
you're disgusting so what you're
supposed to do is like slice it kind of
like what you do with
the uh tongue but there are videos of
asian women
eating this and they'll just take a bite
out of it and after you cook it for some
reason like water squirts out
so it looks like a dick is it some kind
of weiner
no that's yeah that's a clamp it's a
it's like a really long
clamp oh yeah oh see that's what i was
telling you
bro how did you know that i
i don't know dude this thing's vulgar
though look at this girl
[Laughter]
oh my god what are you all doing and she
bit it
oh she's trying to share some of our
culture with you she's not feeling it
that thing bit back on all
i'll tell right what she's taking that
thing down though like a chair all right
chef you might have found a secret
ingredient
fry some of these up chef oh original
recipe right
here let me see another one oh gosh
who is this girl she's creeping me out
oh wow giant
oh no damn girl
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that's a ball
[Laughter]
bad guys papa like girl
you gotta drain that thing yeah oh
man this is sexual as [ __ ] oh man
damn girl bad guy bad guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn boy we back at brother's bar
and this girl is about to get knocked
out right here
is that pepper she's roughing that in
thing leaking bro
oh that's a kneecap dude that's a
grandparent's leg right there
uh-oh there she goes with that sami sosa
sauce right there boy it looks like
chili oil
and chin do you know what she's saying i
don't know it's chinese this is chinese
okay
thank you oh she putting some tempura
crunch roll on that [ __ ]
that's like crunchy that lime seasoning
is getting crunchy girl
oh wasabi that's what that is yeah
dude we should get one and try it we
can't do this
i bet you can playboy
oh gosh damn is that thing aftermarket
it's just are we watching the dark web
is this the dark web
how many are there now
oh it's a four minute video of her just
doing this over and over
probably a million views and are these
good if has anybody had one of these
i've actually had it before the way
you're supposed to eat it which is
sliced
so you're not supposed to just kind of
take a bite out of it like that and
that takes the fun out of it yeah what
they do i want to slap it around and
bite that thing
why why are they i just don't uh
oh it says the go duck is still alive i
feel like this is
some way inhumane it's actually pretty
sad watching her smack it knowing that
it's still alive
she didn't prepare it right what did it
do that was so bad is what i wanted
please be gentle
and it's scary bro someone needs to stop
this woman i agree with that
someone said she slaps it
[Laughter]
so i'm going to delete my search history
just in case
when she started slapping you know a man
wronged her once or twice
oh man oh that's too much man oh
someone netflix are you still watching
someone's daughter
this is disgusting is she draining them
this thing that's mother nature man yeah
damn mother nature's a sexual
what do we got nick we're we'll save the
debate club for next week
all right no place to go from there sure
exhausted clams that was a woo clan
no uh gooey duck geoduck i don't know
how geoduck
call it a geodude how do you say it that
[ __ ] seemed racial this just seemed like
[ __ ] ku klux klans but
it didn't seem hella racial at the end
you just do them cleaning them clams
some units on them bro
them claims down the face damn
you find this clams at high tide bro
looking to ball out
those clams are partying bro i didn't
know the ocean was doing all that
yeah chinese people did oh really yeah
people wild man they'd be wildin dude
who's about to eat that thing
they go out and catch them damn things
damn bro they make them hungry
you're going to eat out there so you got
to slap him
[Laughter]
that's tasty bruh give it a hit daddy
there you go
sorry bruh oh i've got cold meat around
it's too much thank you chappelle for
this food yeah thank you guys thank you
guys man yeah
ken yeah
yeah brennan and theo fighter and wait
i gotta go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
brendan ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want the smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]